dix femmes ont été tuées depuis le début
de l'année au québec une série de
meurtres qui donne froid dans le dos
depuis constaté que les conséquences de
la pandémie semble avoir créé une
escalade de la violence
les conjoints violents ont pu resserrer
leur emprise sur leurs partenaires
devant l'urgence et la gravité la
situation j'annonce aujourd'hui un plan
et un engagement ferme de notre
gouvernement au cours des cinq
prochaines années le gouvernement
investira près de 223 millions de
dollars supplémentaires pour lutter
contre la violence conjugale
de cette somme 92 millions iront centre
d'hébergement pour les femmes
163 nouvelles places seront créées d'ici
un an
l'argent servira également à faciliter
la sortie urgente de milieu dangereux
pour les femmes en détresse à permettre
un accès immédiat à une solution
d'hébergement temporaire à bonifier les
ressources pour l'organisme sos violence
conjugale et à augmenter le financement
des organismes des deux hommes ayant des
comportements violents
les hommes qui sont violents ou à risque
de le devenir et qui sortent de chez eux
pour aller chercher de l'aide avant de
frapper mais il faut être capable les
prendre en charge et de les aider et ce
faisant de sauver leurs femmes et leurs
enfants une aide nécessaire pour les
différents organismes
le travail est loin d'être terminé des
actions restent à mener pour pérenniser
les conditions optimales de dispensation
de service des maisons changer en
profondeur les mentalités et agir
globalement pour pallier aux failles
dans la lutte contre la violence faite
aux femmes
c'est pas juste l'argent c'est
l'intention de mettre des mesures
efficaces et structurante en place perso
c'est aussi la très bonne nouvelle de
cette annonce qu on sait qu il ya eu de
l'argent qui est injectée
dans la dernière année qui a mis du
temps à arriver sur le terrain
j'ai même pas aller tout arriver encore
dans lequel il faudrait pas que ça se
perdre dans les dédales bureaucratiques
pour salariés sur le terrain le futsal
arrive vite
le gouvernement fera d'autres
s'annoncent au cours des prochaines
semaines notamment sur les changements
qui seront apportés au système
judiciaire également aux différents
corps policiers de la province
ils se marient michel lauzon
radio-canada à montréal